هناك مثل صيني يقول بانه ليس مهما ان يكون
القط ابيض او اسود المهم ان يصطاد الفئران
وربما هذا المقوله تنطبق ايضا حول طبيعه
الانظمه السياسيه لانه يمكن ان تكون انظمه
ملكيه دستوريه ويمكن ان تكون تحقق نجاحات
وتقدم جوابا اجتماعيا واقتصاديا بالنسبه
لشعوبها وايضا هناك انظمه جمهوريه يمكن ان
تقدم هذه الاجوبه بكل تاكيد يوم ازمه
الديمقراطيه في العالم ككل وليس فقط في
العالم العربي ان هذا الشكل الديمقراطيه
ما بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه شاخ اليوم
اليوم ما نشهده من اصوليات من شادو اليوم
من تصاعد نزع الشعبويه عن مستوى العالمي
تطرح اشكالات جديه فيما يتعلق بمساله
الديمقراطيه هناك اليوم نقاش كبير جدا في
الغرب فيما يتعلق بجدوى
الديمقراطيه وجدوى الانتخابات لان هناك
مواقع مختلفه للقرار ليست فقط الحكومات
والبرلمانات وبالتالي بكل تاكيد وليس فقط
في العالم العربي ايضا احتل المواطن على
في العالم الغربي هو يبحث بالدرجه الاولى
عن مصالح يبحث عن الامال الاقتصادي وعن
الامال الاجتماعي وعن المستقبل بالنسبه
لابنائه وعلى هذا الاساس حتى في الغرب
يعني الدورات الانتخابيه تقوم اساسا حول
الاجور حول معدلات البطاله حول كل هذه
القضايا الاساسيه القضايا الكبرى الان
اصبحت وراءنا بحكم التحولات التي عرفها
عرفها العالم وبالتالي العالم العربي لا
يمثل استثناء في هذا في هذا الباب العوده
الى النقاش فيما يتعلق بالمقارنه بين
الملكيات العربيه والجمهوريه العربيه هو
ان هذه الملكيات لم تتح لها نفس الفرصه
لكي تقدم اجوبه حول هذه القضايا ولا يجب
ان ننسى ان اغلبيتها يعني استثنينا بعض في
السعوديه او المغرب فاغلبيتها كانت في
العشرينات من القرن الماضي وك على اثر
تفكك الدوله العثمانيه وفي ظل صراع الكبير
صراع الكولونيالي والاستعماري والحضور
الانتداب البريطاني وبعدها ايضا كانت هناك
صراع مع الاتحاد السوفياتي حلف بغداد
ومحاوله الحد من تمدد الاتحاد السوفياتي
الى المنطقه بحيث ان كل هذه الانظمه
الملكيه لم تنشا في ظروف طبيعيه ولم تنشا
في ظروف عاديه بل اكثر من هذا مثلا في
ليبيا اكتشاف النفط لم ياتي في مرحله
تساعد النظام الملكي لكي يظهر النتائج
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه المرجوه بل عندما
وقع انقلاب القذافي استفاد من الثروه
النفطيه ولكنه لم يتم استثمارها كما تم
استثمارها في البلدان الخليج ولهذا اليوم
عندما نريد ان نقدم تقييم الملكيه
والجمهوريات هو هذا المستوى الذي تحدثتم
عنه فيما يتعلق بالرحاء الاقتصادي اليوم
كل المؤشرات لدي احصائيات